Women are not only
supposed to havechildren,
they are supposed to want to.
This existed everywhere. It existed
in the ways that adults spoke to me
when they posed questions in the context of
"When you get married ..."
"When you have kids ..."
"Don't you want a family?"
A value thatI have always understood
about myself was that
I never wanted children.
It's so easy toforget the roles
that society places on us
are so much more than mere titles.
Whatabout the weight that comes with them,
the pressure to conform to these standards
... the fear associated with questioning them,
and the desires that we cast
aside toaccept them?
Your choice to embrace or forego motherhood
is not in any way tied to your
worthiness or identity
as spouses, as adults, or as women ...
and there absolutely is a
choicebehind maternity,
and it is yours and yours alone.